hey guys i'm ryan right i'm gerry today
we wanted to just say thank you thank
you thank you because we have hit
200,000 subscribers that's right uh-huh
that's not that's what you were doing
nothing was to honor was it was numbers
it was just just math can you those I
just like how chemically large the dicks
can you mimic two penises and wow that's
hard no you do two tongues yeah unless
you put something in your mouth that
could expand both your cheeks but then
you would only be locked it kind of like
a Marlon Brando did for the Godfather
well yeah we want to say thank you but
before we go into the thanks and some
other announcements or questions I want
to ask you guys this just happen to come
in the mail while I was away in SD for
comic-con this is the $100,000 this is
the 100,000 subscriber silver something
i don't know everyone said I was we were
supposed to get one and I don't know
what they were for I guess it's like an
award yeah it's like an accolade that's
exciting their their honor I opens
excited well see what it looks like
rejects unless it's like a big one of
those spring boxing gloves that comes
out like in the cartoons yeah just
punches us in the space and squirts [ __ ]
on our face that's not like any cartoon
I've ever seen no family you don't watch
the same cartoons I did I don't do are
you ready for this jerbear I am can I
can i yeah take it off no you we both
take it off 1230 a clear piece of paper
100,000 subscribers that's more than
double the size of a packed Roman
Colosseum yes and more than 10 times a
times the number of people who set the
human Domino world record head out to
read these are both things I was hoping
we would surpass and we did it that was
the goal that was on our vision board
yeah you know I really like to pack more
than the Roman Colosseum and I really
want to do more than those Domino people
to commemorate your milestone of a
hundred thousand youtube subscribers
please accept with our congratulations
this silver play button we know you'll
continue to create amazing con
and it is amazing and bring in more fans
well now we're at 200,000 thanks for the
late send youtube so we'll keep looking
for new ways to reward you thank you for
being awesome sincerely Thomas C Pickett
vp global head of content operations
YouTube Thomas Pickett he wanted a shout
out she was so Thomas again look at what
you're looking at it Oh [ __ ] awesome
wow that's [ __ ] insane careful cuz it
might fall out and I like a look at this
is awesome thank you you too Thank You
YouTube Thank You Thomas Pickett I pick
it your picket your your Buttle don't
he's free works for the company yeah
they can they could wow wow so cool this
is so [ __ ] cool Thomas can we get two
of these so Jerry can take one home cuz
I'm not do you deserve this they like
like this is this is you you built this
man like I do deserve me were the
guiding force yeah I would love to have
one but but you know we wouldn't be here
if it was me Wow well thanks sure that
is so [ __ ] awesome Jerry I wouldn't
be able to do any of this without you
taught me how to edit do the lights work
the camera he taught me everything I
know so if it wasn't for him none of
this would be here that's why it's him
and I together forever yeah right baby
see everything Herenton well gang
comments on naval day he's like who is
this good I even you since day one yes I
was like I know I'm not here as much but
come on man well thank you you too this
is [ __ ] awesome um I should gonna go
to my girl right here yeah any time you
watch videos what yep that's right no no
not even you should just have it on a
necklace like every time you react those
are really cool like just the play
button like on but I do want to say a
couple of things before this video wraps
up besides the reaction videos which I
know you guys all love we do other
things on this channel 2 we got movie
reviews spoiler reviews movie news
sketches the vlogs occasionally I'm not
a big fan of doing vlogs by the way I do
them
be [ __ ] a man you know you owe it to
everyone to give them an intimate look
into your life like when I go to Jerry's
deli exactly that's that's what the
people really want to see besides
reactions what more do you want like I
just posted a short film a sketch that
we did with Sally Jerry co-directed it
and did the whole deep in for it check
that out but yeah if you guys want more
of that I want to do those once a month
i'm thinking of doing a sketch like once
a month and yeah man if you guys want
that will do it you know we'll do it
it's phase three of the real reject
cinematic you so yeah I mean what more
do you guys want and also we're gonna be
doing sketches once a month and I've
been saying this for the longest [ __ ]
time but it is still something I work on
weekly reel-to-reel rejects well
something's came out my mouth
reel-to-reel rejects it wasn't my
testicles no sorry it's just that's
somebody else's that's reel-to-reel
rejects will be happening it's gonna be
the music channel so please keep a
lookout for that working on it weekly
not i'm not gonna give a datum when it's
gonna come out because i keep [ __ ] up
the release date on that but yeah thank
you you too I mean thank you guys cuz
like we wouldn't have this it weren't
for y'all that's not sure well if it
weren't for you and then like it just me
okay they have nothing is on the
subscribers actually because you created
200,000 accounts I create 200,000
accounts i bought like a hundred
thousand of them and that i actually
watch and comment on my own videos
200,000 times a day so because nobody at
you nurs I've comes just so far into
death if you happen to come across this
video wow you're the only real person to
have come across this video
congratulations and tell us what you
want Dan you know feedback is always
good keeping in touch with what the
people want you know can't guarantee you
do all of it cuz you know we still got
to be true to ourselves but this is true